[Applaudissements]
en effet bonjour à tous bonjour Sarah
ella merci d'être avec nous ce matin
vous êtes la personne qui incarne le
service national universel on vient de
le dire ce SNU voulu par Emmanuel Macron
alors c'est compliqué ça prend du temps
pour sa mise en place on va en parler on
se demandera aussi ici cela pourrait
être une réponse à une partie à la crise
en tout cas qu'à travers une partie de
la jeunesse et dont on a vu la
traduction avec cette explosion de
violence après la mort du jeune Maël
qu'elle est d'ailleurs votre diagnostic
à vous après c'est terrible journée
qu'on connu de nombreux quartiers dans
toute la France qu'est-ce que ça dit de
l'état de la jeunesse votre secteur
ministériel donc
à ce drame et la mort de ce garçon il y
a eu des émeutes ça dit beaucoup de
choses ça dit beaucoup de choses mais la
priorité c'est d'abord le retour à
l'ordre au calme c'est la priorité des
priorités mais ce que j'ai vu c'est
aussi une infime minorité de jeunes qui
ont été émetiés particulièrement jeunes
le plus jeune avait 9 ans une moyenne
d'âge de 17 ans pour certains films bien
sûr c'est une infime minorité parce que
moi au quotidien je vois quoi je vois
des jeunes qui s'engagent je les
sapeurs-pompiers des gens qui s'engagent
dans des assos des jeunes qui sont
sidérés de voir leur quartier aussi
brûlés détruits de voir des écoles
détruites et au quotidien je vois ces
jeunes là parce que je ne veux pas qu'on
finalement qu'on les oublie que eux
deviennent invisibles à nos yeux c'est
pour eux que nous engageons par contre
j'ai vu aussi dans l'expression de ces
métiers plusieurs choses la première en
tout cas en partie ça a été de brûler
des symboles de la France des écoles des
bibliothèques ou encore je pense aux
mairie mais de l'autre côté aussi des
comportements des comportements de
délinquants à les piller un magasin
prendre votre expression madame elle
Aeri est-ce qu'il y a pas quand même un
sentiment global de révolte de colère de
l'incompréhension de ces jeunes après ce
qui s'est passé à Nanterre et notamment
de rapport avec la police est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas une réalité profonde dans le
pays et dans une de jeunesse de la
France des jeunes et métiers qui s'est
retrouvé en comparution immédiate devant
les juges n'a exprimé en réalité de
liens de lien direct ou de cause de
cause politique de ce n'est pas ce
n'était pas le sujet la réalité c'est
qu'il y a eu un drame ces drames à créer
un mouvement d'effroi dans notre pays la
justice est saisie et et
la vérité sera établie et c'est la
priorité cependant cependant ce qui a ce
qui montre ce que les profils des
émeutiers montrent c'est que il y a une
part entière d'entre eux ont moins sont
des mineurs ont moins de 18 ans et donc
quelle est la place la responsabilité
des parents mais là c'est un enjeu
énorme
je vous repose néanmoins la question
vous considérez vous madame Sarah Eric
il n'y a pas de problème entre ce que
ressentent non pas une infime
nourritomie énormément de jeunes dans
les quartiers et notamment le rôle de la
police qui est pointé par exemple par
certains observateurs étrangers par
l'ONU par diverses organisations qu'en
pensez-vous est-ce que tout va bien dans
le meilleur des mondes là-dessus c'est
une question extrêmement claire le
travail au quotidien avec des
associations qui renforcent le lien
jeunesse police je pense évidemment à
raid aventure dans le cadre du smul il y
a des échanges pour construire cette
compréhension respective mais la réalité
elle est où elle est que qui a rétabli
l'ordre au quotidien dans ces quartiers
qui protège les plus fragiles d'entre
eux qui protègent en réalité ce qui
n'ont besoin et bien ce sont nos
policiers excusez-moi de vous contredire
excusez-moi aujourd'hui quand on voit la
vitesse à laquelle le calme est revenu
en particulier dans les endroits où il y
a eu des violences c'est grâce aux 45
000 policiers et gendarmes qui ont qui
se sont mobilisés mais aussi grâce aux
élus locaux qui sont sortis aux
animateurs et aux éducateurs dans ces
quartiers qui ont appelé à la raison et
au retour au calme mais aussi
ce que ça peut recommencer il suffira
d'une autre étincelle parce que les
problèmes de fond ne sont pas réglés
qu'en pensez-vous et bien c'est pour ça
que la réponse qui a été donnée encore
juste hier par le Président de la
République c'est on va pas tomber dans
les petites facilités qu'on entend
par-ci par là depuis quelques jours de
réponse à l'emporte-pièce la situation
est importante elle a une réelle gravité
et cette gravité elle s'inscrit dans
quelle place pour l'autorité le civisme
la citoyenneté le rôle de chacun le rôle
des parents bien sûr mais aussi la
question du rôle individuel de ces
jeunes jusqu'à sanctionner les parents
les mettre en cause même
financièrement lorsqu'il y a lorsqu'on
considère qu'il y a un défaut
d'éducation de leurs enfants ce sont eux
le responsables quand vous avez quand
vous faites quand vous faites venir au
monde un enfant les parents je rappelle
que c'est souvent des familles
monoparentales et des mamans qui sont
débordés en quelque sorte un regard
toujours très très individuel sur la
situation mais quand vous avez un enfant
de 11 ans dans la rue il n'a rien à y
faire et donc la justice elle condamne à
quoi à des stages de parentalité
obligatoire à l'interdiction de d'avoir
un jeune de 11 ans dans la rue bien sûr
qu'il y a une responsabilité à tenir et
un accompagnement humain évidemment qui
l'accompagne mais ne soyons pas où sont
les bien sûr évidemment des sanctions
vous savez déjà du mal par parfois elles
peuvent être multiples elles peuvent
être fin elles peuvent être éducatives
mais on va être très clair quand vous
avez quand nous sommes dans notre pays
nous avons des droits beaucoup de droits
et bien nous avons aussi des devoirs et
ces devoirs et bien c'est d'abord de
s'occuper de ses enfants mais évidemment
pour les pour les majeurs d'avoir des
punitions et je crois que la justice
rendent des décisions fermes et c'est
très bien Madame est-ce que vous pensez
que Gérald Darmanin le ministre
d'intérieur a eu raison de dire que
parmi les personnes qu'il avait vu dans
les commissariats qui avaient été
interpellé il y avait je le cite des
Kevin des Matéo une façon de dire que
tous ces jeunes n'étaient pas d'origine
immigrée de leurs parents ou de leurs
grands-parents est-ce que c'est une
réalité parce qu'ils avaient aussi en
commun visiblement et vous l'avez dit
une haine des institutions de la France
des mairies des écoles c'est ce qui fait
leur point commun vous savez ce que je
vois oui c'est construire reconstruire
un lien avec la France apprendre à aimer
la France il se trouve que aujourd'hui
nous allons commémorer Léon Gauthier un
grand homme un homme qui s'est engagé
après l'appel du général de Gaulle et le
dernier des commandants Kiefer c'est un
homme qui a dit un jour a des jeunes qui
faisaient le service national universel
qui lui ont posé la question très
simplement et de manière très jeune mais
pourquoi vous êtes parti jusque là il
leur a répondu on m'a appris à aimer la
France ces jeunes nous avons besoin de
les accompagner dans cette dans cet
apprentissage de cet amour de la France
mais soyons pas naïf quand Gérald
Darmanin dit ça il dit quoi il dit ne
tombait pas dans les stéréotypes qu'on
essaye d'entendre aujourd'hui ou que le
Front national que l'extrême droite que
le RN plaide sur quasiment tous les
plateaux des enfants de l'immigration il
y en a dans notre pays mais la France ne
regarde personne comme ça elle regarde
chaque jeune qu'il soit d'ailleurs jeune
bénévole engagé qui essaie de s'en
sortir ou jeunes délinquant comme
français ou pas 90% des personnes qui
ont été interpellées étaient françaises
et c'est comme ça qu'on doit les
regarder la transition avec le service
national universel donc que vous portez
sa mise en place aux yeux des
téléspectateurs des Français qui nous
écoutent ce matin elle est compliquée le
président avait dit que notamment même
dans ses vœux le 31 décembre qu'il
allait le mettre en place ce service
national universel or la prochaine étape
c'est 12000 jeunes plutôt excusez-moi 12
semaines prises sur le temps scolaire à
partir de la rentrée prochaine sur le
mode facultatif on est loin du service
universel
et ça généralise très bien il se trouve
que l'année dernière 32000 jeunes sont
partis en séjour de cohésion c'était une
année qui a permis à beaucoup de jeunes
de partir cette année c'est une
nouveauté beaucoup de jeunes en attente
il y a plus de 10000 jeunes sur liste
d'attente pour les séjours de joints et
de juillet mais au-delà des gens dans
liste d'attente qu'est-ce qu'ils font
ces jeunes
qui arrivera certainement un jour avec
un débat parlementaire nécessaire mais
ce sera un débat parlementaire mais
avant d'aller chercher une modalité
c'est quoi la priorité des jeunes qui
donnent 12 12 jours de leur temps de
leur temps personnel de vacances qui
ensuite s'engage dans des associations
ou dans des collectivités qui évidemment
les vins drapeau mais au-delà de ça
vivre de la mixité qui ne s'affront pas
mes dialogues qui dans le fond
construisent une marche dans leur
parcours de citoyenneté et bien c'est
une France bien plus unie
ouais le succès n'est-il pas au
rendez-vous
excusez-moi et les parents d'élèves sont
contre ce projet qui va enlever du temps
scolaire
quelques syndicats quelques 9 jeunes sur
10 sont très satisfaits quand ils le
font un tiers des jeunes qui le font
viennent parce que un autre jeune leur a
dit à quel point ça les a transformé moi
je suis fière de cette jeunesse qui
s'engageait qui se mobilise maintenant
on a ouvert une nouvelle opportunité
celle de faire des classes engagées et
c'est à dire que il y a l'engagement
volontaire personnel c'est ce que un
certain nombre de jeunes font et je les
salue d'ailleurs
en SNU il y a environ 20000 jeunes en ce
moment même qui font des séjours de
collision ils sont ils sont beaux ces
jeunes c'est la jeunesse de France et
demain ce sera parlementaire qui
tranchera vous madame elle aéri à titre
personnel vous considéreriez que
l'obligation de faire ce service serait
un progrès qu'on revienne au service
obligatoire
par contre la certitude que j'ai c'est
plus de jeunes le feront mieux le pays
se portera mais quel est votre sentiment
quel est votre préférence aujourd'hui je
construis en réalité cette
généralisation un temps on arrivera non
ce sera ce sera l'expression de la
majorité parlementaire qu'il le
souhaitera mais je suis convaincu que
chaque jeune qu'il peut peut le faire
d'ailleurs c'est gratuit parce que c'est
un investissement de la nation dernière
question qui n'a rien à voir votre
collègue du gouvernement Marlène Chapa
est dans la tourmente la commission
d'enquête du Sénat à pointer la gestion
dit-elle cette commission accablante du
fond Marianne doté de 2 millions et demi
d'euros elle peut rester au gouvernement
madame le fait que c'est d'abord notre
gouvernement par la voie de Sonia
bagages qui a saisi l'inspection
générale pour un premier rapport j'ai
évidemment ça reste ça reste l'article 8
de notre Constitution et c'est une
décision qui appartient évidemment au
présent de la République mais je ne veux
pas une chose et bien que les questions
qui sont posées autour du fond Marianne
et Lude le fond le fond du sujet le fond
du sujet c'est la lutte contre l'islam
radical les conséquences qui ont amené à
la décapitation du professeur Samuel
Paty et tout ce que jamais puisque
jamais la justice est saisie on aura des
conséquences et des conclusions mais
Marlène Schiappa est une ministre
engagée ça c'est ce que j'ai vu pendant
plus de trois ans au sein du
gouvernement précédent et au sein de
celui-là mais n'oublions pas le combat
aujourd'hui il est contre les
séparaistes quel que soit leur forme ou
leurs origines parce que notre pays a
besoin d'unité plus que merci beaucoup
Sarah er